Uh,
we have heretofore flown at a relatively high altitude with the likes of Adam
Smith,
a Karl Marx,
Joseph Schumpeter,
Faa Hayak,
uh,
and today,
and continuing from here to the midterm,
we are going to deal with real businesses and it is our,
uh,
considerable privilege to have with us.
Sharon Oster who is a Harvard Phd in economics,
uh,
is a widely thought to be the wisest owl on the management of nonprofit
organizations anywhere in the world,
uh,
and is the Fredrick Wolf professor of entrepreneurship at the School of
Management and is in addition to that,
uh,
dean of that school.
So please help me welcome Sharon Oster.
Thank you all in my,
uh,
in my youth.
I taught at Yale College and I taught generations of undergrads,
intermediate micro.
Um,
so it's nice to be back,
uh,
amongst you teaching something a little bit about economics.
I hope to warned you,
but I'm going to treat it like a business school class,
which means I'm going to cold call on you.
And people in the back should know that I especially like clung on to people in
the back because they tend to doze otherwise.
Um,
so you might want to change your seat.
so,
uh,
let's think about this case a little bit.
So imagine yourself,
you're one of the three entrepreneurs,
Ferrari gold and Dylan.
The world is your oyster and Sam's,
hence,
here you are,
you've founded this firm.
You've got a product that's this kit that can be used in heart surgery,
big market.
There's a million people who need heart disease,
who need some kind of heart surgery every year.
Growing market,
we're all getting fatter,
we're getting older,
we're getting weaker,
we're getting less healthy.
You might think that's a problem for President Obama and the health care,
but it's an opportunity for our entrepreneurs.
This is that you even in the US,
they could imagine $1 billion market,
uh,
in this business.
Not to mention the rest of the world where people are also overeating and
getting less and less healthy over time.
And yet when we,
when the case opens,
they seem like they have some worries on their mind.
So if you were one of those individuals,
[inaudible] guys in this case,
what are you thinking about?
Okay.
So what do you mean by marketing?
What's,
what's the issue?
Well,
we do do a lot of money and help out consumers,
but you have to work through the physicians.
They're the ones
grading.
Okay.
So one set of questions.
We're going to have our set of questions about the buyer and it can be a lot of
quit talking about the buyer,
but let's just get that up there as one set of things we're worried about.
What are you worried about?
Worried about the,
the competitiveness.
Good.
So you know,
at the moment and let her have it.
She's doing okay.
Uh,
so,
so at the moment,
um,
I only have one competitor,
so what would we call that if we were an economics class?
I do happily.
Okay.
Now one of the things we,
now we're back to Wa police.
If there any kind of a sensible duopolies,
they're probably doing pretty well.
This duopolistic my competitor.
What's his price point look like?
Great.
Yeah,
till he,
I'm charging fast and bucks from my thing.
What's he charge in?
Anybody remember the number?
5,000 no,
that's they're good.
They're good.
They know the numbers.
So,
so you know,
I'm thinking to myself,
you're worried about the competition,
but I got one competitor and he's charging five times my price.
That makes me look like I'm pretty good.
Is there something else you worried about?
Good.
Okay.
So one thing I'm worried about right now is my existing competitor but or
doesn't tell me that I should only worry about a static competition.
Desi,
what is Schumpeter's model about what Ha,
what's happening with competition?
Creative destruction
roll.
Okay.
So with things like better worry about is not just the EC stamped was hard port,
but I bet to think a little bit about who else is coming.
So I'm going to be thinking a little bit about what Michael Porter,
who you also looked at,
I guess is new entry and how do I understand new entry.
And then if I think about the flip side of Schumpeter,
not only am I worried about some new guys coming in and destroying me,
but as I come in,
I'm of course competing against some existing players.
So I need to think a little bit about
existing players
and the way in which they are attacking this market,
this market.
And one of the things you're going to observe a bat almost every new product as
it enters the market,
even if it thinks of itself as a new product,
it has existing competitors.
So many of you may have kindles.
If you look at kindles,
the kindle is obviously also worried about what's happening with the Sony reader
and all the new things that look like a,
but really from the point of candles from Kendall's point of view,
it's real job at the moment is converting all those people who are buying hard
covered books.
Okay?
So it is thinking a little bit about conversion of uh,
consumers from the way in which they are currently used to solving a problem to
your new way of solving a problem.
So we're going to have to think here in competition,
not only about the guys that are doing it our way,
but the existing players.
And we're going to have to think about these things in the context of set of
issues involving the customers,
how I connect to the customers,
how I deliver to whoever these customers are,
and not to think about that.
Um,
a set of different um,
uh,
products,
for the needs of our,
uh,
of our people.
I'm going to stay with those two,
um,
things for awhile and then Doug will help me pull down the slides to get to some
other questions in the end.
But this is going to take care of us for a little while.
So let's stick with the competition part of it first.
So before I came along,
kind of how we set that people got their heart,
a problem,
self guy in the back with the pink shirt and the last row.
MMM,
good.
And do you have a vague idea about,
of these 1 million patients about how they divide up?
Anybody else remember about the numbers
to the nap?
Perfect.
Um,
so the cabbage,
it's about 350,000.
And the NGO plasty
Oh,
if it's a number like that,
you can just yell.
You don't have even have to raise your hand.
We're much more casual group than that in business school.
Um,
so I've got two different ways of doing it.
Let's stick with you.
Kick up my candy.
Good.
So tell me a little bit about,
uh,
my organization cardiothoracics competing against competitors in each of those
two markets.
One
word,
good.
Whereas the bypass,
it was usually in that case,
creating more trauma.
Okay.
So one of the things about this particular product is in its infancy,
it could only do one or two vessels at a time and that limited,
limited it really pretty much to this side of the picture.
Because most of what we were doing this side of the picture involved as you
indicated,
a little more drastic,
cutting a and typically then more treatment of multiple.
So generation one sort of focused on
this part of the market.
Now,
as you indicated,
the technological trajectory was to more and more vessels.
So we're going to spend a little bit of money for this firm and we're gonna move
to not only solving those problems,
but solving those problems.
Does that change come without a cost?
As I moved from generation one degeneration two to generation three,
I get more and more vessels.
Do I lose anything
if the market over and over again?
Okay.
So one set of questions is,
as I'm doing anything technological,
I'm going to have to invest real cash in this one,
if to think a little bit about that.
But is there anything else I lose as I move from one generation to another?
Yeah.
Okay.
Well that's true.
It's hard to do more vessels because I've got more things I'm trying to do as
it's beating.
But there's something else I'm doing is I moved from generation one onward.
Yeah.
Great.
So if you think about this product in the beginning it had to kind of
technological features.
One was it dealt with the bleeding,
heart beating part,
bleeding heart,
uh,
and the second one hit at a smaller cut.
Okay.
So you didn't want to cut all the way through people.
You actually wanted to have a little bitty hole,
uh,
so small incision
and it turned out the,
the beating heart eliminated some of the neurological problems and the small
incision made people recover a little bit faster.
So they were different elements of the product that we liked.
And when we moved from the kind of only a couple of vessels,
too many vessels were giving up on some of the functionality associated with the
product by cutting us cutting up a patient's a little bit more.
And that's another feature that Schumpeter and others have talked about,
including clay Christianson who talks about disruptive innovation that when you
make a product change,
it is,
it is often the case that you don't just,
um,
improve and prove and prove and prove.
You give up things.
There are trade offs that you're making and the trade offs are not just,
it cost you more money and you get more functionality,
but sometimes you actually push along one dimension and you're drawing back
actually in what,
in the qualities of another dimension
in this situation.
Why put the money in and give up the small incision piece just to enable
yourself to move into this piece of the market after all the one or two vessels
market is the biggest chunk of the market and it's pretty darn big.
I'm just a little guy.
Why don't I,
you know,
manage as I,
as I am focusing on that part of the market.
Why is that?
I have to go,
why is it I decide to transform myself here in the back,
the woman in the corner,
you have to say that louder for me or slower though.
I got a piece of Panay and get it all.
So let's start again.
We're good.
We're all
good.
Okay.
So one of the things I'm going to be thinking about here as I'm thinking about
technologically what to do to my product is that when I changed what I can do
technologically,
I am picking a different set of markets that I'm trying to compete against.
And these markets are going to look very different in terms of the kind of buyer
issues and the complimentary is,
and we'll talk about what I mean by that in a minute for each of these two parts
of the market.
So I am choosing my competition in some sense by choosing my technology I'm
choosing to go against here I set of who's doing these cabbage things?
These are surgeons.
Okay,
so these are surgeons.
They're cutting people up.
Who is doing the angioplasty,
what?
What looks different about that?
These are cardiologists.
They're being done in a different kind of an office,
much less invasive procedure,
very different features associated with these two parts of the market and my
ability,
given what I am to compete in each of these two markets,
it's going to vary much.
Very much so.
The technological trajectory is influenced by the economics and the competitive
piece of the story that you are not just imagining yourself a bunch of
scientists in a lab just trying to make it better,
better,
better.
You've got a sense set of managers on top who were saying,
you know what?
We need to have an improvement on this dimension because otherwise we're never
going to be any place in this marketplace.
And a decision was made and we're going to turn to figuring out why this
decision was made,
that it was going to be important to be in this part of the market and not just
this part of the market to get myself some more functionality with the multi
that with multi vessels.
Okay.
So to think about why I needed to go that way.
I want to switch over a little bit to this piece.
We're going to come back to this part in a minute as well and I want to think a
little bit about the buyer issues.
So the woman in the back said,
if I want to do something about,
uh,
knowing my,
my technology,
I've got to figure out what is the consumer want
that the relevant decision maker in this case.
So I'll put that here.
I got up,
I got a patient,
I'll call that patient the consumer.
So when people go,
when they're trying to have some heart procedure,
did they just,
you know,
there's something,
the matter with your heart,
they just come up to you and say,
Gee,
how do you want me to do that?
Well,
how do you think,
what proceeds you think I should use?
So who else is a decision maker in this situation now?
Oh,
and in fact there are actually three different doctors you might think play a
role in this situation.
The one you mentioned as a surgeon.
Good.
So there's your basic GP or whatever it is.
You have some guy you go,
you've put on,
I've got a pain in my chest,
he says you better do something about that.
And then there is a interventional cardiologist who does this piece of the
business.
Okay,
so you've,
you,
some doctor says go see somebody.
And typically he actually says,
go see this guy and this guy figures out can he help you or can she help you?
And if not,
they send you to a surgeon.
So you've got interveners are decision makers all along,
uh,
the doctor element.
Is there anybody else you think that if I'm the inventors of this little kit,
is there anyone else I need to talk to,
need to think about?
Yeah.
Okay.
Insurance Company.
So it turns out one of the curiosities about health care,
and it's the one that's bedeviling the Obama team now in terms of figuring
things out is we have this breakage of the link between people who make
decisions about things and the people who pay for it.
So in this situation,
the patients have some stake in the procedure.
The doctors have a lot to say,
but the poor insurance companies
and or the government or actually doing a lot of the paying for it.
And needless to say,
and that kind of arrangement,
eventually the insurance company starts having your opinion too and making its
opinion felt.
And if you are in the business of medical devices or Pharma in any way at all,
you're going to be thinking a little bit about how's your insurance company's
going to reimburse for this kind of thing.
Is there anybody else that has an opinion about this?
Yeah.
Hospitals.
Why do the hospital's care
so good?
So hospitals actually turn out to have an interesting set of issues about this
particular thing.
Hospitals to the extent that they are reimbursed by insurance.
And that's going to be true for most of the patients in this,
uh,
in this,
environment are reimbursed on what's known as a capitated basis,
which means an insurance company says to you,
if you're treating somebody who has a particular heart problem,
I'm going to give you a fixed amount for it.
That's quite a difference from the way we used to,
uh,
insurance used to pay,
which was you treated somebody,
let me see what your bills are.
I'm going to pay you in an attempt to get some kind of efficiency.
They actually went to a system sometimes called DRGs,
um,
in which they said,
you know,
for uh,
men,
average more or less healthy guy who has this problem,
I'm going to pay you x to treat him if I'm going to pay,
if,
if that's the way I have my hospital reimbursement happen.
How does the hospital feel about my particular device?
What do you think?
Okay.
So one thing it doesn't like is it's just costing them money.
So it's kind of just taking it off the top.
Mike.
There be anything about if they would like,
yeah,
back
to recovery.
Uh,
again there could be other people care about the mortality in particular.
But the first thing you said was about recovery time.
Why might the hospital be especially interested in that?
Yeah.
Well because
in
the run you recover and get them rolling.
Okay.
So it's actually going to bury for different hospitals depending on the contract
that they're going to get.
So for some hospitals I just give you a fee and that would mean if I get,
if this procedure gets you out of your bed and to home faster,
that's benefit for the hospital because they basically only have to keep you in
three days,
not seven.
I saved some money.
On the other hand,
what does this device,
due to the amount of time I need to use it as an operating surgeon
probably increases it.
And from the point of view of hospitals,
most hospitals are more constrained in operating room time.
Then they are in hospital bed time.
So again,
it's gonna depend a little bit out in the hospital how they feel about this and
a little bit on how much we've pushed down in terms of the insurance.
But the hospital is definitely going to have some kind of say now notice
something about these groups.
They all have opinions.
They all have a role to play in the,
in the kind of decision that's going to affect my ability to compete in these
parts of the market.
Did they all have the same kinds of preferences?
Guy In the orange?
Talk to me a little bit about how each of these players are a couple of these
players.
Mike feel about,
uh,
the,
I the idea of introducing this kit that enables people to operate on your heart.
Let me
actually,
like doctors can be,
uh,
less technologically inclined.
I mean their previous
system.
So each one of the buyer.
Okay.
That's a little vague.
So let's sharpen it up.
You can sharpen it up for us.
It's not wrong.
It's just a little vague.
Yeah.
Okay.
So like sharpening
in terms of the pension and consume.
I think what he was trying to say was that with these new technologies it will
require greater training but then Dr. May or may not be able to afford or go
through.
Okay,
go ahead.
The technologies will do
if there's a higher risk,
involve as many testings as well medicine more so that could offset like the
Persian preference going under the knife to have something that isn't that
tough.
Good.
Okay,
so couple of issues here.
One is there's certainly a question about the doctor training and one of the
things that's going to keep me awake at night as an entrepreneur is thinking a
little bit about the doctor training,
which we are going to get to in a couple of minutes and certainly the doctors
are going to be right away at me and saying,
okay,
how am I going to get to learn?
That kind of thing and you can already begin to see.
It's not going to be the kind of thing I'm going to have a course that I charged
for.
There's going to be,
I'm going to have to figure out some way to incentivize these guys to come to my
particular class and learn something about,
we'll talk about what that is.
The other thing I heard you say was something about risk.
So let's think about the risk issues for the surgeon versus the patient and how
they weigh those things.
Now in theory,
if we're doing surgery,
what's the medical benefit of this particular product?
A guy in the red in the back.
Okay,
so one thing it may do is reduce mortality rate.
Although it's a little bit tricky in the beginning because we don't know how
good the doctors are going to be.
The initial real kindness consumers sale people piece of this was less on the
mortality.
More than one.
Yeah.
Okay.
So some of it is I can reduce your recovery rate.
So if we think about that,
does the doctor care a lot about how fast you get back to work?
Yes.
Okay.
So one of the things we might think about the recovery angle is that the patient
is going to care more than the doctor.
So that's going to be an element
recovery time in which we've got an asymmetry in terms of how much the people
value these things.
What's another element?
Yeah,
the trauma,
neurological complications that develop.
So subject.
Yeah.
So another thing about this surgery is you have to be on a heart lung machine
and that actually has neurological problems potentially associated with it.
So we've got something that it's actually potentially going to reduce some of
our neurological problems.
It turns out for various studies people have done who study doctors and medical
care kinds of things.
If you thought about the trade off to a patient and asked the question,
how much incremental risk of death would you be willing to face to avoid the
kind of um,
very serious neurological damage?
The answer to that question is very different for patients than it is to
doctors.
From the doctor's point of view,
the danger of having someone die on the table is enormous relative to any other
problem.
From the patient's point of view,
there are times in which they are willing to trade off and say there are some
conditions that I could have that frankly I would just as soon take a chance of
dying.
And that's been actually a very complicated set of dishes for doctor patient
relationships across a whole range of different operative uh,
and surgical procedures.
And it says to me in this situation where we are talking about heart,
um,
heart recovery kinds of issues,
those tradeoffs are going to be calm,
potentially very large.
So when we have a risk of death that's going to be larger for the doctor and the
risk of damage.
It's going to be conversely more important from the patient's point of view.
Yeah.
Now let's think a little bit about these different players and look at these two
parts of the market.
Because we started this by saying that these guys did a whole bunch of
technological things to try to move into this part of the market as opposed to
staying in this rabbit larger part of the market.
Okay.
As we think about these being the deciders among the things,
why is it technologically imperative to get out of this market and into this
market?
Yeah.
Good,
good.
So some people call about this,
the gatekeeper problem.
So it turns out in this particular market,
I've got a gatekeeper problem,
which is my big competition are the ones that are going to basically handle this
themselves and their tendency to then say,
you know,
you've got,
you've got two vessels,
I could deal with it,
but I think he'd be better off going here.
Now that we have a kit is going to be a much reduced.
So I've got a problem that my competitor
is a gatekeeper for me.
But there is,
there is another problem all selling this,
attacking this part of the market.
Let's think about it from the point of view of the patient.
How does the patient who has just one or two vessels damaged feel about these
two procedures?
Yeah.
Angioplasties already quit.
So if you think about what this is,
um,
I,
Chile did some,
uh,
work for Boston scientific in this market,
um,
as an economist.
And they,
even though I was only an economist,
they actually wanted me to watch one of these procedures for reasons that
completely escaped me.
Um,
but if you watch one of these things,
it's the person,
the patient is awake the whole time.
There's a,
basically what they do is there's a little blockage in one of your arteries.
They put a,
a thing that looks sort of like this ball smaller up your leg.
Think we've it up until it gets to the right part in which there's a blockage.
They have a balloon at the end of it,
they have a little machine that blows up the balloon.
The balloon just presses against the wall of the artery.
Uh,
all the junk that was clogging it up goes psh,
I'm kind of floats away.
We hope to wherever nirvana is.
Um,
and then they take it out and off you go.
So it's very noninvasive.
That's very appealing to the consumer.
I've got a gatekeeper here who's a cardiologist.
What would the insurance company rather have me do?
Oh,
this is way cheaper.
Xander,
your plasty things are way cheaper than anything in the cabbage side.
So anyone that's an insurer is going be thinking you've only got one or two
vessels
go this way rather than trying to do a less problematic version of this.
So from the point of view of solving the needs of these people,
I can't stay in this part of the business.
I don't have enough value ad to offer in that part of the business.
I have got to go to the only part of the business in which I have potential
value Ed,
which is this part of it.
And for that it says to me,
even though I'm going to give up something in functionality,
I'm going to need to give that up in order to make myself more attractive in
that part of the business.
Because from the point of view of everything,
pretty much everything,
these guys care about this thing,
this dominated.
Now we'll come to the little more on the competition in a minute.
Yeah.
Let me backtrack slightly from that.
Um,
aggressive comment I just made because there is one problem.
For those of you that read carefully,
there is one problem that the angioplasty has that would be improved by me
actually,
you know,
trying to do this in a less invasive way.
Yeah.
Great.
So an issue that we have from the point of view of an issue that this competitor
has,
it's something medically,
it's called restenosis so that I could have this done,
but I have to do it many times.
And then you could think now what the patient is thinking is to,
I want to have this with the kit done once or do I want to have this done every
other year?
Which sounds a little less appealing than it sounded a minute ago when I thought
we could just do it once and for all.
So initially you might think,
well it looks like there is some advantage I could build on in my discussions
with patients and doctors and frankly even insurers and hospitals that would
make me on a crack of alternative to this.
But if I was thinking in a shrimper Tyrian way and going to build my business
around that,
what else would I want to be thinking about in terms of that strategy?
So a strategy that says,
okay,
I'm looking at what these guys are like now and I'm thinking about how I look
relative to them and there's something they don't do very well and I'm going to
just kind of hammer in on what they don't do well.
What's the potential worry that I might have about that?
Yeah.
Good.
So keep the mic so that tells me if I were going to go that way,
what would I need to be doing?
You have to use Spanish to the interventionists
or eliminated.
Okay.
So I got to figure out a way to get over the gate.
What's a way to get over the gate
target
target to patients so that they have been,
so we could think a little bit about what's been happening.
Those of you that watch television,
probably none of you anymore.
Uh,
one of the things we've seen in the health care area is much more direct
advertising to patients.
Even for things that you would think your doc,
these are things your doctor is going to prescribe for.
You were warning,
make a deal in one way or another.
There's an attempt in a lot of areas to avoid the gatekeeper by going direct to
the patients.
How easy is that to do in this market as opposed to a market like um,
allergy relief.
Okay.
You stairs there markets now for whatever,
Claritin or some one of these drugs that is prescription.
So the only way to get it is go to your doctor,
but the,
the line is go to your doctor and ask him to prescribe this drug for you.
Is it going to be easy for me to have on television something it says go to your
doctor and tell him you don't want an angioplasty.
You want your cabbage John with the beating heart kit.
So why are you all laughing?
What's ridiculous about this?
Cool.
Okay,
so eight's complicated information asymmetries.
Exactly.
Right.
You could think,
okay,
I could go to my doc with that,
but what the hell do I know?
Right?
I mean really,
I'm not going to trust my own view of this even if the television telling me so.
But here's actually another,
just a sort of business issue which is there in some sense aren't enough people
watching TV for whom that message is relevant.
Even if I could really focus in on TV and do what I'm going to be,
it's going to be a problem.
Okay.
But there are some possibilities maybe on the web.
So you could imagine a set of web advertisements that when you're clicking on
something that says,
what do I do about heart problem?
It clicks up to me.
Talk to your doctor about the beating heart port kit.
So there are some technological things directed marketing that actually allow us
in various markets to get away from gatekeepers and go direct.
But there's actually another problem with building a lot on this strategy as I
think about building a strategy to attack an existing player.
Any of you have game theory and have you ever take game theory?
Did any of you had a do economics majors?
Okay,
good.
I'm picking on you because you should know this business econ major.
If you're thinking about um,
you're thinking about positioning yourself against an existing competitor.
I'm looking at what this guy's doing now.
What else should I be looking at?
Exactly.
So I need to be thinking this guy's,
what is he going to be just sitting around kind of,
you know,
reaping in the profits.
He's going to be thinking about here you came with this new business,
what should,
and you're attacking me by my,
by virtue of my wrist analysis.
What am I going to do
now I want to think a little bit about if I'm the designer of this thing is who
are these players?
Anyone have any sense of who the guys are doing the angioplasty business,
producing the,
these balloon catheters and so on.
Well they're big companies.
Companies like some love.
You may want to go work for Sunday,
Boston scientific,
Medtronic,
Johnson and Johnson.
What's true about these big companies?
They spend a lot of money on R.
And D.
Okay.
Cause they make a lot of money.
They have broad product lines,
they have big cash flows,
they spend a lot on r and,
d,
You some little pipsqueak making hard port are gonna wreck your whole business
on the idea that you,
you uh,
you can attack these guys by saying they're going to have you going back to the
hospital a lot.
You can be sure they know that's an issue for their company and they're throwing
a lot of money at it.
And in fact what we see in this business is actually we get very shortly after
this a physician I knew drug eluting stent that allows for less restenosis that
they have spent many,
many,
many millions of dollars on.
So I think it is very dangerous to stick with the two vessel thing because you
know these guys a in the first place,
you don't have a value proposition for consumers and B,
you've got very strong competitors who have a lot of money to throw at the
particular problem that they have.
So Cup,
just a couple more things.
We want to think about the training issues.
If I'm actually going to make this work in this business,
I have got what economists would call a complement with an e not an I.
I've got,
I got to somehow,
you know,
this kid doesn't do it itself.
This kid is used by doctors,
surgeons.
So I've got to figure out a way to train those guys.
And in the,
in the,
uh,
in the case they talk about some of the ways they try to train these guys.
What is,
they offered them trips to Hawaii.
What's the problem with the trips to Hawaii to learn?
Go
just to look at the electrical Polish to another music they've heard about it,
that interested just to learn more about it on that unit.
Okay.
Actually stayed for the surgery.
Good.
And since you're an ECON major,
we'll test you a little more on the ECON.
So there's a problem in economics known as the selection problem.
Okay.
So how does the selection problem play into this?
What kind of doctor's got to Hawaii?
Okay.
They like beaches and when they go to Hawaii,
I'm paying for their transport.
But what am I not covering?
What's the magic word there?
Only three magic.
Oh,
thank you.
That's the magic word.
You Bet.
So a strategy that says come to Hawaii,
you tracks a bunch of doctors who aren't doing many surgeries because they got
plenty of time to come to.
Why the people that I want to attract are the people that are doing a lot of
surgeries because they are an annuity word from those of you interested in
finance.
Once I teach them every year,
they do more surgeries every year.
I don't keep reteaching them every year they do something.
Moreover,
I want the guys who are in teaching hospitals like Gail cause they gonna teach
all the guys behind them and I want them to be big users.
And that's why most of the training for these kinds of things actually happens
in the hospital,
doesn't happen in Hawaii.
Hawaii sounds great to someone who doesn't know anything about doctors,
what do you want to do is you want to go where they are training where they are,
where there's low opportunity cost,
uh,
of learning as a way to capturing still it's going to be a tricky piece.
Um,
it's going to be a tricky piece to try to do it.
So we have a situation in which it looks like a good idea.
We've got big hurdles to go over in terms of actually having a value add that's
meaningful.
Suppose I could suppose I did have something that I condensed.
I got enough doctors to know how to do it.
I got enough stories to consumers and others that I got around the intervention.
Cardiologists is a lot of ifs about this and are getting some penetration of
this thing now what am I worried about?
Yeah.
Okay.
I could worry about is insurance going to cover it?
But suppose I got that.
I've managed to convince those insurance companies that,
you know,
this has been to get people out of the hospital faster.
This is going to be a good deal.
Here I am.
I'm starting just starting to make money.
What is,
what do we know when you're just starting to make money?
Yeah.
What happens to you?
What kind of eScience is economics?
The dismal science.
Why is it the dismal science?
Because the minute you start making money,
what happens?
People enter the market.
That's the glory of why price has come down in this situation.
What kind of a product do we have?
We have a little platform for beating heart.
When we convince the doctors to adapt,
we wanted to have something that was going to look pretty generic because I
wanted to give doctors some sense of you can learn how to make this and I'm not
going to hold you up.
Eventually.
The easier it is to copy.
However,
the more problem I have from new entry,
so even if I can crack this problem by attracting the right buyers,
solving the complimentary problem,
changing myself technologically to hit the only part of the market in which I
have a chance to compete,
I'm going to have a problem that I'm going to have the risk of new guys coming
in and the more attractive I make this from a generic point of view in the
beginning of my market,
the more problem I'm going to have protecting it in a later part of my market.
And that in some sense is really the Schumpeterian story that says to me the
nature of an innovation is coming in against existing players with something you
hope will be a better idea but then worrying and the end about other people who
are going to imitate you until finally there are enough of them till another new
comer comes in with another disruptive innovation that looks better than what
you had before.
So I have to actually go teach my Mbas.
And so your last five minutes Mr. Ray is going to complete for you.
Yeah.
As you can see she's done that.
No.
The question,
the syllabus poses for you is concerned with social learning with whether the
mark and companies like this one,
our instruments by which society learns through both success and failure.
Okay.
Uh,
does anybody see a learning component to this?
Okay.
It's good.
A mic for somebody.
Let's go to purple shirt right here.
What's the learning process here?
Well,
I mean,
I mean something more abstract and bigger.
Is Society smarter in an in any important way toward the end of this story then?
It was at the beginning,
I suppose
hold up turns out being a dentist because they didn't fit it a bit excited
because then in which case we had a technological innovation that will maybe
save
some lives,
reducing recovery time.
But if the product never enters the market,
I mean,
I guess,
I guess if there is this pressure to innovate,
even if it doesn't end at the mark,
maybe,
you know,
the angioplasty guys will be out there trying to compete with it even though
it's not really a major competitor.
Okay.
So in actual fact,
there's a learning story with a yes answer ama learning story with a no answer.
And the learning store with the yes answer is very obvious.
Well,
learning answer with the failure story is partly that we know one bad idea,
so we don't have to repeat it.
Uh,
but in addition,
it's part of a larger incentivation process which compels everyone to be
thinking about the next step beyond what they already know how to do.
In the case for Monday,
which is,
its URL is posted on Classes v two.
We have the Polaroid land camera,
uh,
invented by Edwin land and it's,
it is a,
uh,
less bloody story that is a little like the,
the one we just did a,
the difference is that it is closer to the mass consumer and is in that way a
more,
uh,
typical champagne,
her story about how innovation in consumer product disturbs and old equilibrium
in conventional photography,
and then becomes a defender against a new disruptive technology with the
emergence of digitization.
Uh,
we'll see you on Monday.